over the weekend on day five of counting
the ballots Democrats claimed victory in
both the Nevada and Arizona Senate races
giving them control of the Senate no
matter what happens in the upcoming
Georgia runoff there's lots to be said
about those races and all the things
that could have been done differently
but before we get into any of that in
the spirit of bipartisanship I would
just like to congratulate the Democrats
on finding the votes that they needed in
under a week this time just 4 four days
of counting ballots in the most crucial
races is a big improvement over the last
election and it's a sign that by next
time they might even be able to fit all
of their machine malfunctions and
security camera outages into just three
days who knows I'm Michael Knowles this
is the Michael Knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment on Friday is from Leo leovich
who says Arizona 7 million people
takes three weeks to count the ballots
Florida 21 million people takes one day
to count the ballots they better start
teaching them to count over 100 in the
Arizona schools the problem is I think
they do teach them how to count in
Arizona I think that those Arizona
Democrats know how to count real well
and that actually is the reason why it
took so long for them to count and until
Republicans get serious about those
issues they can expect more of those
same results in the purple states in the
states that don't take care of the
election Integrity measures now when you
want to take care of the Integrity of
your Workforce you got to check out
ZipRecruiter right now head on over to
ziprecruiter.com
Knowles there's so many people in my
life I'm thankful for you know my family
and my friends and my employees and my
colleagues you know we can be grateful
for those people in our Lives who make
our work easier which is why it's so
important to have the right people on
your team and if you want to hire those
people for your business you need zip
recruiter you can try it for free right
now at ziprecruiter.com Knowles
ZipRecruiter uses power default
technology to find and match the right
candidates up with your job you can
easily review these recommended
candidates and invite your top choices
to apply additionally zip recruiter's
complete Suite of tools make it so easy
to filter review and rate your
candidates four out of five employers
who post on the recruiter get a quality
candidate within the first day so if you
want a stress-free hiring process trust
me you will be so thankful that you
tried zip recruiter just go to our
special URL to try it for free at
ziprecruiter.com Knowles at
zippercruiter.com
ZipRecruiter the smartest way to hire
pretty weird stuff out there in Nevada
really disappointing and kind of really
makes you scratch your head because the
race went from plus two percent for the
Republican Adam laxalt with only 20
percent of the vote left to count
all the way to plus 0.5 percent for
Catherine Cortez masto the Democrat
so that means that every single Precinct
just about that was counted later where
all those ballots came in later pretty
much all of them broke very very heavily
for the Democrat incredibly heavily you
might say
now it's a little weird too when you
look at the breakdown between the senate
race there in Nevada and the governor's
race in Nevada because
what you what you see there is that more
people voted in the senate race than in
the governor's race it's kind of weird
to think that someone would walk into a
Ballot Box well I guess we don't do that
anymore but that someone would fill out
a mail-in ballot and then only vote in
the senate race and not vote in the
governor's race that would be kind of
weird it's also kind of weird that 16
000 people might vote for Catherine
Cortez Master the Senate candidate that
would not vote for sisilak the governor
candidate that's kind of weird it's also
kind of weird that the live stream
cameras covering the vote counting areas
in Washoe County in Nevada just went
down in the middle of the night they
went completely dark from 11 24 pm on
the night of November 9th all the way
until 7 53 a.m on the morning of
November 10th just coincidentally right
there in the middle of the night right
while they're in the heat of counting
all of those votes it's kind of weird
don't you think
don't you think that's just a little bit
weird
but you're not allowed to say that you
see because if you raise any questions
whatsoever about these votes that take
long long time to count with all these
kinds of weird irregularities and the
voting machines break in Arizona and
then the security cameras break in
Nevada and then the numbers are kind of
implausible actually if you raise any of
those questions you are of course
an election denier oh spooky so I I made
this point on Twitter I said
the longer it takes to tally the votes
the less inclined you ought to be to
believe the results
this is pretty basic stuff folks this is
the kind of stuff that Barack Obama said
10 years ago this is the kind of stuff
that both parties used to agree on and
the Tweet went viral because it's true
and people know that it's true and then
once these results came in it's just
amazing how whenever it's a real nail
biter takes a long time to count for
some reason it seems almost always to go
to the Democrat in those cases and so I
I joked as I joked in my monologue I
said you know congratulations to the
Democrats on finding that the number of
votes they needed in a shorter period of
time this time
and a lot of people thought this was
kind of funny it's either laugh or cry I
guess there's a man in Bremer who is
basically the voice of the liberal
establishment he's one of the great
exemplars of the liberal establishment
especially on foreign policy but uh on
domestic policy as well and in Bremer
retweeted my post and said
thankfully hard to find active election
deniers post midterms but still a few
out there like me I guess because I'm
pointing out that it's a little weird
how the election was conducted in Nevada
in Arizona I'm not raising questions by
the way about Pennsylvania
I wish we didn't have the mail-in
ballots I mean there are certain things
we still need to do to tighten up
election Integrity but I'm not raising
questions about a whole bunch of states
I'm raising questions about the states
where they seem to have those
malfunctions and it seems to take a
really long time to count all the votes
the sort of states where if they were
foreign countries the U.S state
Department would be now running an
investigation into the subversion of
democracy
if it took Argentina or Iraq
the the amount of time to tally the
votes that it's taking Nevada and
Arizona there would be calls from the
U.N from the U.S state Department for an
investigation because of a subversion of
democracy but because it's happening in
our own country we just turn a blind eye
because it benefits the Democrats so
anyway I point this out and Ian Bremer
calls me an election denier
nobody who uses the phrase election
denier in Earnest is to be taken
seriously it's one of those phrases that
is simply used as a cudgel to Club the
people over the head to Club your
political opponents over the head the
Democrats are very good at this kind of
rhetoric and this is one of those
phrases
phrase election denier
is was established and is propagated to
call to mind Holocaust deniers
that's why you have it's kind of a weird
phrase to call someone a denier of
anything that's the point that's why
they also say climate denier now if you
don't think
that the sun monster is going to kill
all of mankind in 10 years well
ocasio-cortez made that prediction like
four years ago so now we're down to what
six years eight years I don't know uh
but if you if you question that thesis
you're not called a skeptic you're not
called a rational person as you should
be you're called an election denier and
the whole point is to draw a comparison
to Holocaust deniers so uh I think this
is very silly it's also especially silly
because the Democrats are the ones who
have been rejecting the results of
elections
much longer than Republicans with much
less of a reason to do so and in in many
more cases than the Republicans are
doing that
nobody has faith in the electoral system
that we currently have nobody has faith
in it the Democrats don't have faith in
it because they accuse Republicans of
suppressing the vote
and furthermore because the Democrats
don't believe that we are legitimate
participants in our sacred democracy
they say that we're fascists and
terrorists and a domestic threat and
we're we're threatening the whole
country by our very existence that's why
the Democrats don't accept the election
results when we win
we don't accept some of the election
results when they win sometimes because
they rig the elections and brag about it
in Time Magazine and they're allowed to
say that and that's really good and
they're allowed to brag about it in
their magazines the moment that we bring
it up though with any kind of criticism
that of course is unacceptable and we're
election deniers and worth threat to our
democracy so what's going on in the
house the the house right now is still
up in the air
the Senate the Democrats took it took
him four days but they figured out how
to keep the Senate now the House of
Representatives is up in the air it's
going to come down to some races
probably in California there is some
maybe good news which is that Lauren
bobert's District uh in Colorado I like
Lauren a lot she's a friend of mine
she's a conservative uh Lauren is up a
little bit over her Democrat Challenger
Adam Frisch this very likely will come
down to a recount the recount could take
weeks so
don't hold your breath and then the the
control of the house will very likely
come down to some California races we're
looking in Orange County at Katie Porter
uh Democrat Mike Levin Democrat they're
holding on to slim leads there in Orange
County uh Ventura County's 26th District
representative Julia Brownlee
uh was re-elected the Republican Matt
Jacobs had made kind of a move might
have threatened her but uh that went to
her uh then we've got well we've got
California's 13th congressional district
uh that's going to be a tight one
there's the 22nd that's a tight one so
anyway there's there's just a lot of
races and if we're waiting for
California to uh you know give us a
great hope of a republican country then
probably we're going to be waiting a
very very long time I can't help but
notice can't help but notice
that when we talk about the Red Wave and
why didn't the Red Wave materialize the
Red Wave did materialize in some states
materialized in Florida that's for sure
now a lot of people are saying well it
materialized in Florida because of the
leadership of Ron DeSantis no doubt
there's a lot of Truth to that but it
didn't only materialize in Florida it
materialized in Texas it materialized in
Ohio it materialized I can't help but
notice in the places that after the last
election
took election Integrity seriously
so yeah you can give a lot of credit to
Ron DeSantis for that forget about all
the other things DeSantis has done he
took election Integrity seriously he
tightened up the election rules they did
the same thing in Texas they did the
same thing in Ohio
you gotta Wonder had they tightened up
the election rules
made it a little uh less prone to fraud
in places like Arizona like Nevada would
we have seen that Red Wave trickle out
in the way that we did
is it is it really that the the
consensus narrative right now is the the
right wing conservative candidates are
just not playing very well we need to go
very squishy and moderate and Trump is
really bad and we need to just become
the party of Mitt Romney again that's
that's the consensus narrative certainly
on the left but uh in certain quarters
of the right as well I don't think that
is really borne out by the facts look
what happened in Florida look what
happened in Texas look at Ohio for
goodness sakes JD Vance was running as
an extraordinarily trumpian candidate in
Ohio
I don't think that was necessarily
the takeaway I think the takeaway is
probably the advice that FDR gave to LBJ
when LBJ lost one of his first political
races FDR said you did a great job
campaigning but you forgot to sit on the
ballot box
now when you want to sit down on a
really important piece of equipment that
can help your body get back into shape
you got to check out Echelon Fitness
right now text Knowles to 81 81 81 are
you struggling to reach your fitness
goals well as it turns out having
world-class instructors plus a community
of hundreds of thousands of people who
are working toward the same goal really
really helps the guys over at Echelon
Fitness have it all worked out Echelon
Fitness is the affordable way to get
workout equipment a workout community
and an instructor's motivation right in
the comfort and privacy of your own home
Echelon fitness's Connected app provides
thousands of Live And on-demand classes
with great music to keep you moving you
can work out anytime day or night their
full range of affordable workout
equipment includes stationary bikes
smart rowers Sleek Fitness screens and
an auto folding treadmill these are all
connected to the echelon fitness app for
The Full Experience Around the Clock
classes including full body workout
programs will keep you coming back one
membership covers family of five I love
love my Echelon for a limited time our
audience can get a free bike or rowing
machine with a 24 month membership that
is a free bike and these bikes are
incredible or a rowing machine I don't
have one of those yet but I kind of want
one maybe I'll maybe I'll text and that
way I can get a free one I text Knowles
can W Las to 818181 that is Knowles to
81 8181 to claim your free bike or
rowing machine
text to Knowles to 81 81.81 message and
data rates may apply C terms for details
The Establishment line on the midterm
elections is that it's totally Trump's
fault and Trump needs to go here you
have it from longtime GOP pollster Frank
Luntz when he's attacking the next
generation of Republican leadership mark
my words the party's going to turn
against him and the angrier he gets at
other conservative Republicans the more
that they're going to punish him with a
loss of support and a loss of faith and
confidence in his message and what he's
what he brings to the political process
I if I were advising him right now I
would tell him to take a very long
vacation simply disappear for the next
30 days because he's destroying himself
every single day by attacking Ron
DeSantis Glenn Younkin people who other
Republicans respect and appreciate and
voted for in big numbers in the previous
elections
you might agree with that advice
you might disagree with that advice
regardless though the problem is that
Frank Luntz having been around for a
very long time in GOP politics having
close associations with the more
establishment leadership in the House of
Representatives especially but in the
whole GOP
he doesn't have a ton of credibility
here
when people like Frank Luntz attack
Donald Trump or even sort of concern
Troll and say listen I'm really worried
about you sir you need to stop doing
what you're doing you need to stop
attacking your primary Rivals you need
to just kind of go away for a little
while when when people like Frank Lyons
do that it doesn't carry any weight
because Frank Luntz has not liked Donald
Trump from the beginning and represents
a part of the GOP that Donald Trump
came in to destroy When Donald Trump
came in in 2015 that was a hostile
takeover of the GOP when when people
said Donald Trump's not a real
Republican
Trump's answer and the answer of his
supporters was you're damn right that's
the point I'm not a regular Republican
that's why I'm doing so well you're
seeing a similar attacks from the
lieutenant governor in Virginia
it's Winsome Sears the lieutenant
governor to Glenn Younkin is going out
on TV now especially after Donald Trump
came out and attacked her boss and
ticket mate Glenn young and and
Winston's here says it's time for the
party to move past Donald Trump
when we look at the mission and as a
marine we're looking at the mission and
you know the voters have spoken and they
have said that they want a different
leader and a true leader understands
when they have become a liability a true
leader understands that it's time to
step off the stage and the voters have
given us that very clear message so how
does that does that apply within the
Republican Party lieutenant governor to
Donald Trump that it's time to step off
the stage
yes A house divided against itself
cannot stand and and indeed that's where
we are today and as I said before
America is the prize why do we want want
to win elections it's because we've got
to learn to love to get love each other
live together uh govern together and the
voters are saying enough is enough
whoa whoa whoa
why do we want to win elections so we
can all sort of just Kumbaya together
that's why that's not why I want to win
elections yes I do want to love one
another yes I do want to take care of
our fellow citizens
and the way we're going to do that is
not by
you know getting together in a drum
circle and passing the Peace Pipe and
just coming together that that will be a
consequence of
of conservative government
we want to win elections
so that we can have conservative
government and we can suppress the bad
stuff that the libs are doing
and we can enact the good stuff and we
can suppress falsehood and we can
promote truth and we can suppress
ugliness and promote Beauty I don't want
to win just so we can all just kind of
get along man I want to win so that we
can win so that we can do stuff that the
purpose of winning is not just so that
we can have some R's in office and they
can get invited to the cocktail parties
the purpose of winning is to is is not
to say okay that's the end of the fight
but that's the beginning of the fight to
wield government power with Justice
within proper limits with in a very
moral way to do good to actually do
stuff okay and not to just maintain this
desiccated liberal status quo this is
why when people hear this kind of stuff
from Winsome Sears and win some Series
has an impressive record in many ways
not saying she's the number one star in
the GOP she's gonna be running for
president 2024. but she's got an
impressive background and winning that
race with Glenn young in Virginia was a
very important thing
especially because it's a purple
Commonwealth
but when I think when voters here
from kind of regular run-of-the-mill
politicians which compared to Donald
Trump everybody is a regular
run-of-the-mill politician when they
hear the stuff we just need to come
together you know we just need to
Kumbaya they reject that they recoil
from that because I think no I don't
want it we come by Yad for a long time
we Kumbaya with Romney we come by Yad
with John McCain with Kumbaya with John
Boehner we kumbayaad with all these
people who sold our country out and and
basically just conceded on every major
fight to the Democrats
it's not that there are no legitimate
criticisms of Donald Trump it's not that
there are no legitimate Arguments for
Trump even in in 2024.
arguments against his running but but
attacks from people who are
viewed as opposed to him from the very
beginning are are going to do nothing
other than boost support for Trump
case in point
Larry Hogan Larry Hogan governor of
Maryland says Donald Trump lost us the
midterms and so he's got to go away
look this was this should have been a
huge
Red Wave it should have been one of the
biggest red waves we've ever had because
you know the President Biden's approval
rating was so low one of the lowest
historically
um more than 70 percent of people
thought the country was going in the
wrong direction and yet we still didn't
perform and uh I think Common Sense
conservatives that focused on talking
about issues people cared about like the
economy and crime and education they did
win but people who tried to relitigate
the 2020 election and focused on
conspiracy theories and uh you know
talked about things the voters didn't
care about they were almost universally
rejected and I think it's it's basically
the third election in a row that Donald
Trump has cost us uh the race and it's
like you know three strikes you're out
okay that's an argument that's an
argument that you're going to hear
repeated a lot
the problem for that argument is the
people who are making it
because no conservative in America cares
what Larry Hogan thinks about anything
Larry Hogan is a big lib so no one cares
he comes from the Romney wing of the
party and so anyone that you're trying
to persuade with that argument is not
going to be persuaded by Larry Hogan
okay
very very few people are this is why
the 2022 midterms are going to be fought
over for a very long time Democrats are
fighting over it right now by counting
all those ballots but the Republicans
are going to fight over it too and
they're going to be fighting over who to
blame right now the sort of consensus
mainstream narrative is it's all Trump's
fault and the Trump candidates lost and
the non-trump candidates won now I don't
think this is really borne out by the
data the the way that you can make that
argument is by disregarding the 100 plus
well over a hundred candidates that
Trump endorsed who won his record was
pretty good but then what the people who
blame Trump will say is no no but in the
crucial races and the ones that were
kind of tight and questionable Trump's
endorsements were really really bad and
Trump did make some questionable
endorsements in 2022. there's no doubt
about that but then you're going to see
a question of what exactly is at fault
here
is it election Integrity is it the
mail-in ballots is it the week-long vote
counts is it all the rest of it is it
Donald Trump is it and there's good
Arguments for both of those things Texas
Florida and Ohio that's a good argument
for the election Integrity side of it uh
Dr Oz was not a great candidate that's a
good argument for blaming Trump okay or
were there larger factors in play as
well was abortion an issue abortion very
well did play a disproportionate role I
think it was totally worth it if we can
overrule Roe v Wade but that's a
question that's going to factor in here
there are all sorts of issues
but people are not just going to move on
they're not going to say okay the
election's over we're going to move on
one we can't move on because there's
still a runoff and the Democrats are
still finding ballots in Washoe County
but or at least they were a couple days
ago but the reason we can't move on is
that as has been the case from the
beginning the 2022 midterms are little
more than a facade
for a kind of puppet match for the 2024
presidential primary which has already
begun and we're going to need energy for
that primary and when you want some
energy you're gonna have to check out
Black Rifle coffee right now go to Black
riflecoffee.com use promo code Knowles
while today's coffee often comes with
hints of soy and social justice eh gross
Black Rifle delivers an entirely
different experience bold strong and
delicious Black Rifle coffee is the
coffee that I choose to get me through
the day Black Rifle coffee companies
veteran founded and operated their
mission is to help service members
successfully transition from the
military into entrepreneurship they
provide assistance to Veterans who seek
to launch businesses of their own with
the goal of helping more companies such
as Black Rifle become a reality Black
Rifle is committed to hiring 10 000
veterans and they're well on their way
as for the coffee itself which frankly
is my number one concern Black Rifle is
extremely selective about where they
Source their coffee beans they're very
disciplined when it comes to ensuring
the freshness of every bag go to Black
riflecoffee.com use promo code Knowles
for 10 off your first order or when you
sign up for a new coffee Club
subscription the subscription gives you
free shipping on all coffee Club orders
Early Access to Club deals and
promotions and special discounts from
their partner Brands that's black
riflecoffee.com promo code nulls for 10
off your first order or when you sign up
to become a coffee Club member Black
Rifle coffee supporting veterans and
America's coffee
the best argument I've seen against
Trump
and specifically in favor of DeSantis
though I I guess you could make this
argument about other GOP candidates but
right now DeSantis would be the guy to
benefit from it
is
that Donald Trump's poll numbers are
strong
that's the that's the argument it seems
like it's not an argument for DeSantis
and it is an argument but
Donald Trump's poll numbers are strong
and steady and they don't really move up
all that much
whereas
other candidates and specifically
DeSantis they've got a lot of runway in
front of them so morning console
just did this poll
Donald Trump's support has dipped in
recent months
uh that's the that's the headline that
you see in the media however
if you look at the poll numbers and you
take out some of the kind of
jumps and falls
the consistent numbers you see it's
about 48 of potential GOP voters
supporting him
now in August he reached a high of 57
percent
but then he dipped right back down to 48
in November now Ron DeSantis his numbers
are quite different back in May of 2021
Ron DeSantis was polling at eight
percent Now 26 percent say that they
would support him in a 2024 Republican
GOP Primary which is very impressive
considering that Rhonda Santos has not
publicly stated that he intends to run I
think most people expect him to run he's
clearly building a national campaign
he's clearly talking to donors but
that's very impressive numbers and so if
you're looking at these two numbers then
you've got to think okay
if Donald dot 48 is very very impressive
but if that's the wall then doesn't
matter 48 in a buck 50 will get you a
cup of coffee you have to get you have
to be able to grow in the campaign
depending on who runs and how the
numbers you got whereas if DeSantis is
jumping eight percent to 26 wow sky's
the limit how far can he go now there's
another little wrinkle here though
that's the argument you're going to be
hearing from the DeSantis stands but
then there's another wrinkle here which
is what about that little blip hold on
wait what's going on though in August
desantis's number Trump's numbers rather
jumped to 57 among potential GOP voters
whoa how do you go from 48 to 57 what
happened around August that would have
done that oh right Joe Biden targeted
Donald Trump and sicked his federal
agents to kick down the door at
Mar-A-Lago and steal his stuff
oh right
the New York attorney general was
talking about indicting Donald Trump oh
right you hear the entire political
establishment moving to attack Trump and
this is very likely going to determine
how Trump Rises or Falls
it has I think little to do with what
Rhonda Santos does he's already doing
everything he can do he's a great
governor of Florida and he's putting
himself in the national news cycle and
he's playing his cards perfectly there's
I don't think there's anything more
DeSantis can do
so what's going to determine it I think
what's going to determine it
is how hard the liberal establishment
goes after Trump
one of the reasons that some people are
still preferring Trump over DeSantis I
think probably the main reason is that
the establishment
just freaking hates Donald Trump and
they clearly want to kill this man and
they're doing everything they can in
some cases it seems illegally or
certainly unprecedentedly as a legal
matter to stop this guy from running in
2024 and the fact that the liberal
establishment is going after him so hard
is for many people a strong argument to
support him
because it tells many people man this
guy is still the one who's right over
the target this guy is still this agent
of chaos this guy is still completely
unpredictable uncontrollable man for all
of his flaws and he has Myriad flaws
this guy is still something kind of
special
if Joe Biden and the doj and the whole
establishment keeps coming after Donald
Trump expect that 48 number to go up
again expect it to spike to 57 expect
Trump to do well in the primary expect
him to take the nomination
if the establishment ignores Trump
with these kinds of numbers
and if Donald Trump keeps
irritating some of his supporters
then maybe you could see a big opening
for especially for someone like Ron
DeSantis who's playing his cards totally
right and who is very very popular with
GOP voters now there's another argument
against Trump which is on this exact
same point and I haven't heard other
people talking about it which is
if you believe that the establishment is
very corrupt and they rig elections and
they're doing things to Donald Trump
that are unprecedented and probably
illegal
then you've got to ask yourself this
okay so you're going to nominate Trump
because of that
but then don't you think they're just
not going to let him win
don't you don't choose if you're really
saying that if things are as bad as you
say that they are then they're not going
to let him win right
but then of course the answer to that
kind of musing is well sure but I'm not
just going to go along and play their
game if the if the establishment says
pick anybody other than Trump I'm not
going to play along with that because
then I've already lost because then I'm
allowing them to control who the GOP
nominee is these are the forces that are
at Play
I think where the where most of the
conversation is right now is about why
did Trump send out that tweet or fake
tweet why did he send out that truth
social comment why did he send it why is
he talking about Glenn Younkin well come
on why is he doing that hey look at
these great policies in Florida and
Virginia and sure that
right that all plays but the crucial
factors here the things that actually
move the numbers
are going to be coming from from
different sources and a lot of it is
going to depend on how the ruling class
treats
the Donald treats the former president
there's kind of a relation to Twitter
you know Twitter now is
in absolute chaos and and Elon Musk is
another agent of chaos and Agent of
Change
Elon Musk comes in and he just
democratized the blue check mark
the tyranny of the blue checks is over
because now if you pay eight bucks you
too can have your own blue check mark
now why would you do that I don't know
because now if everyone can have a blue
check mark then the blue check mark
doesn't mean anything but think about
think about what that means
the blue check mark
was intended for verification
the blue check mark
means that this person is who he says he
is and the reason it developed in the
first place is because if you had public
figures then you would have lots of
accounts come in to impersonate those
public figures so you needed a check
mark to say who is the actual public
figure will The Real Slim Shady please
stand up
now the meaning of the check mark
started to change long before Elon Musk
showed an interest in Twitter
it was when Richard Spencer the white
identitarian activist uh aroused the ire
of everybody and all the people in
Silicon Valley
and so they took his check mark away
it was very strange why did they took
his check mark away why because he was
no longer Richard Spencer
did he cease to be Richard Spencer no
it's because they recognize that the
blue check mark connoted not just
uh a sort of identity and not just a
verification but a certain Prestige if
you had a blue check mark you were very
very fancy it was the sort of Lords and
surfs model of Twitter
and that now
uh now Elon has totally changed that and
the blue check mark just means you paid
eight dollars
is the same sort of thing that happens
with uh our Republic or our sacred
democracy you hear that phrase when uh
Ian Bremer or somebody calls me an
election denier because I raise basic
questions about why the security cameras
went out for eight hours or why it's
taking five days to count the votes you
know stuff that any normal person would
have been able to ask five years ago but
we're not allowed to ask it anymore and
when when the Democrats refer to our
sacred democracy
they don't say our Republic because they
want to tie our form of government to
their own party which is the Democrat
Party and it's ironic because when the
word democracy pops up doesn't pop up at
the Constitution or the Declaration of
Independence does crop up in the
Federalist Papers always negatively
always a disapproval but anyway they
refer to our democracy but one has to
recognize that our democracy or our
Republic or just our system of
government
is not the same one that it used to be
the way that our government works today
is not the way that it worked in 1796.
the way that our government works today
is not the way that it worked in 1885.
or
1955 or it has changed dramatically over
time
so we use the same terms to refer to our
government
our our democracy our Republic or
whatever
but we're not referring to the same
thing we we have the same symbol just
like the blue check mark it's the same
symbol but it means something totally
different than it used to mean even just
a few years ago
and whereas it may not have been proper
or right to
raise questions about the elections 20
years ago 30 years ago 50 years ago
the system has changed the the system of
Elections has changed and the
conservatives are a little bit slow on
this but it's it's the it's the Liberals
main trick I mean this is the thesis of
my book speechless controlling words
controlling Minds number one National
bestseller still selling very well makes
a great Christmas present is that the
Democrats are just much more Adept at
using language and that they a pervert
language as the primary means of
achieving their political ends
so when they refer to these things
when they refer to men as women or when
they're refer to
foreign Nationals as undocumented
dreaming future Americans where when
they refer to rigged elections that they
admitted or rigged in Time Magazine as
you know the the persistent and enduring
symbol of our sacred democracy they're
lying to you they're deceiving you and
and then they Gaslight you whenever you
raise the question whenever you point
out that that that the way that they're
describing things does not correspond to
reality
speaking of how they use language
especially on sexual questions well
radical gender ideologues decry the
harms of Single Sex bathrooms and comedy
specials and dead named celebrities kids
are the ones that are actually suffering
just recently the FDA issued a warning
that prescribed puberty blockers the
ones that transgender activists claim
are harmless and reversible can actually
cause vision loss and brain swelling the
experimentation on children has to end
to fight back we must Expose and defend
the truth such as
has been the case in Mount Walsh's
documentary what is a woman with over 5
000 audience ratings on Rotten Tomatoes
what is a woman is pushing back against
the left's dangerous narratives help us
keep the momentum up by watching and
sharing the movie go to dailywire.com
Knowles today to become a member and
watch it
things are not always what they seem you
especially see this
in the case of FTX
and Sam bankman freed have you seen this
guy
if you I saw I didn't have no idea what
this was
because you know me I'm a boomer you
know I'm older than a boomer I'm
whatever Joe Biden is that's what I am
at least in my mind that's at least how
I identify so I'm not really into crypto
or you know computers or I don't know
Donkey Kong or whatever you kids are
playing out there so I I didn't know who
this guy was or what his exchange was
FTX was a crypto exchange headquartered
in the Bahamas it was launched in 2019
it had accrued one million users by this
year
and all of a sudden
users demanded their money so there was
a run on this exchange they demanded six
billion dollars in withdrawals
and the exchange collapsed why did they
demand the 6 billion in withdrawals they
demanded it because of an article
published by coindesk which revealed
that the two arms of this guy's Empire
Sam bankman freed were
sharing a lot of assets we're doing lots
of dodgy stuff so he had the The
Exchange and he had sort of like a hedge
fund and that there was a back door that
was allowing the money to go between the
two and so their balance sheets were
totally bogus and the thing was pretty
much a Ponzi scheme
this comes out
bankman freed
goes broke and I'm not sure that people
even know where he is right now it's
just he's either the Madoff of Our
Generation or it's the Enron of Our
Generation it's a major major Financial
Scandal and crime and collapse now why
does that matter I always thought the
crypto thing was weird so I never got
all that into it but but people have got
you know people I mean major
institutions invested in crypto and so
why does it matter
why is it interesting to us
well it has nothing to do with crypto or
the Bahamas or anything like that has
everything to do with Sam bankman
Freed's extracurricular activities
is Hobbies
bankman freed was the number two donor
to the Democratic party this cycle
number one is George Soros you're not
allowed to say that though it's an
anti-semitic conspiracy theory to
mention who the largest owner to the
Democrat Party is George Soros who is
don't think he's exactly a practicing
Jew last I checked but anyway the libs
tell me it's an anti-semitic conspiracy
theory and I'm not allowed to mention
that he's the number one donor well the
number two donor is this guy Sam bankman
freed Sam bankman freed gave at least 38
million dollars to left-wing causes and
political action committees committees
and candidates
this is what they do
this is what the libs do
they
use their clout they use their social
Prestige they use their money
to puff up even more their semblance of
virtue they make it seem like they're
the most altruistic wonderful caring
people in the world and yet the point is
always to give them breathing room and
to give them an opportunity to fill
their pockets more and more
you see this on some of the great reset
when we talk about the great reset the
fact that the libs are trying to make
people eat bugs and the libs are trying
to make people live in these gigantic
awful skyscrapers and these tiny little
pods and that they're the the great
reset which is this project of the world
economic Forum which involves some of
the most powerful people on Earth who
say explicitly you will own nothing and
be happy you will you will not have any
possessions well the the flowery
arguments that they make at their
conference in Davos is that this is this
is for the good of humanity this will
allow the human Collective to grow and
progress
and the the funny thing about all of
their schemes and their plans a lot of
which revolve around climate change but
they but they have all sorts of other
doomsday prophecies uh overpopulation
and all the rest of it the funny thing
about all their schemes to address all
of these Armageddon scenarios
is that all the schemes always seem to
make those people richer isn't that kind
of weird
it's not it's not just simple enough to
say well this is a movement from the
radical leftists who are trying to push
their utopian Vision in the world yeah
sure that's part of it
it's also capital
it's also deeply entrenched moneyed
interests who use all this woke nonsense
as a smoke screen to fill their pockets
more and more
it's also that and that's what you saw
from Sam bankman freed
but it was all
an illusion
speaking of left-wing Democrat Illusions
and delusions
an MSNBC panelist is floating a ticket
for 2024. I
I of all that I've heard you know we've
heard about
we need DeSantis oh yeah DeSantis is
great we need Trump I still like Trump
people a lot of people don't like them
anymore I still like Trump we need I
don't know Ted Cruz I love Ted Cruz that
would be great how we need this guy we
need that guy we need this guy I've now
heard this is my favorite ticket
uh MSNBC take it away
let me throw out a couple of other names
if I can so you've got Val demings right
you've got Liz Cheney
um
Sherry Beasley Tim Ryan a top Democrat
suggested to me watch for Tim Ryan in
years in the future to run for president
I mean
I don't know do you count these folks
out is is are many of them maybe the
right candidate in the wrong state
but what about if we have we pair up Liz
Cheney and Stacy Abrams and actually
start talking about Universal voting and
election reform I could see them doing
kind of a czar thing with the
administration that's completely
bipartisan that would be exciting I mean
stuff does turn over and that's what
point is that the president can create
and there is definitely an appetite for
this kind of movement of like how do
there's not one American who has not
experienced an election election day and
said this is flawed there has to be a
better way
before I get to her point on elections
yes I endorse this ticket
I I will campaign
for Cheney Abrams in the Democrat
primary yes this is this is what we need
if Cheney Abrams
run in 2024 some of the biggest losers
in the United States
even with
the power going out and the water pipes
bursting and the camera's turning off
and the machine's malfunctioning even
with that Republicans will win 57 states
so let's do it baby I'm in every all of
the 57 states that Barack Obama
remember that's that's what the
Republicans are going to win if they get
it uh on her point though
she makes a very important Point here
she says they should run on Election
reform
election reform is very important to
people now she is describing election
reform as make it even easier to cheat
rig it even more for the Democrats she
calls it Universal voting
does that mean everybody has a legal
right to vote in America everybody's had
the legal right to vote
for a century and a half
everybody has had the federal government
enforcing the legal right to vote for
what 60 years now at least
so what is she possibly talking about
she's saying basically
make sure that every single person casts
a ballot that means more ballot
harvesting means fewer idea requirements
it means a lot more dead people voting
it means we're going to be counting
until the Democrats win so her what she
means by election reform is really bad
but when she says there at the end she
says there's not one person in America
who's going to vote recently who has
thought this is a functioning system and
she's totally right about that
where's Ian bremmer to call her an
election denier
let's go come on Ian come on liberal
establishment she's an election denier
she's saying that there are serious
problems with our voting system oh right
everybody says that
every single person says and thinks that
it's just that when inconvenient people
when enemies of the established regime
and ruling class when the conservatives
the actual conservatives come out and
say that that's the problem
we're not allowed to point it out
MSNBC can talk about it all day
it's it is a big issue and and I think
conservatives and Republicans should
take her advice seriously to Heart
because
if we want to get results like Florida
and Texas and Ohio
we need really good strong conservative
government in those States yeah we need
the DeSantis model in those states that
would be awesome
but you know Ohio I don't know you
wouldn't say that Ohio is kind of
leading the charge for the conservative
revolution in America in the way that
Florida is right or even Texas is not
doing quite the same thing
what what was the big factor there
especially in Ohio which is kind of a
purple state
now some people are trying to say no
it's a firmly Red State but that's not
quite true
Ohio has is very much in play I don't if
if anyone turned it into a red state it
is Donald Trump actually certainly
before trump it was a very purple State
leaning to a blue State sometimes so
what's the big determining Factor here I
think it's probably the selection issue
and
the Liberals don't want to talk about it
because they're they're winning now
because they were able to rig the
elections using the excuse of covid
the conservatives do want to talk about
it but that's there's that squishy block
the kind of squishy establishment
conservatives who want to be liked by
the New York Times who want to get
invited on CNN who want to seem really
Posh especially look Thanksgiving and
Christmas are around the corner they
don't want to be called a crazy kooky
wacky person by you know their lesbian
purple-haired niece I was going to say
nephew maybe nephew who knows these days
at the dinner table and so they want to
seem like they're really irrespectable
sort of establishment conservatives and
they don't want to raise this question
of election Integrity either
it's important and a lot of the
conservatives the people are that
everyone's looking up to right now
Ron DeSantis
Greg Abbott
they they took election Integrity
seriously especially knowing that that
they and their friends would be on the
ballots they took it seriously and every
other Republican should too today's
music Monday we've got a t-swift video
again I I don't think I've ever
intentionally listened to an entire
Taylor Swift song
in my whole life I don't really know
anything about the girl but her last
song
seemed to me fairly conservative which
was jarring to me because I was told she
was a huge live so anyway the producers
have teed up a t-swift song the rest of
the show continues now if you don't want
to miss it then you got to become a
member and of course you don't want to
miss it so click the link in the
description and join us
[Music]
[Music]